[Music]
foreign
series Anna Kingdom Come comics we now
have a new list on the largest creatures
of Skull Island here we will include all
the big ones that are either seen in the
movies or in the series and also from
the Books and Comics officially
published on behalf of the monster verse
so here are 20 of the biggest creatures
of that place all based on height with
length included in some cases so let's
get to it
at number 20 we have the death jackals
these are hyper carnivorous theropod
like animals with mammalian traits they
possess bird-like feet and their
partially exoskeletal spines give rise
to a thick Mane from the back of their
skull their heads down their bags their
reptilian faces have long snouts and a
mouth filled with bone crushing teeth
seen in the comics both of Kong they are
6 to 10 feet or two to three meters tall
number 19 the giant crocodile seen in
the new series the giant crocodile is
grayish in color with darker osteaderms
all around its back it was 6 to 10 feet
in height or 1.8 to 3 meters but was
much longer than the death's jackals it
was seen as a ferocious and persistent
semi-aquatic Predator that can both swim
and run at fast speeds
number 18 the trapdoor crab these are
giant crustacean monsters that dwell in
the beaches of Skull Island they are
essentially large crabs around 3 meters
to 10 feet in height and are armed with
large red pincers their torso is
primarily a bluish characters almonds
exoskeleton they hide in the Sands as
Ambush Predators waiting for the prey to
come close
17 the Swarm Locus this is a creature
with an elongated body that resembles a
centipede featuring numerous limbs
extending from its sides its legs are
exceptionally long and resemble the
branches of a tree its circular mouth
like a lamprey is equipped with a
complete ring of sharp teeth swamp Locus
can reach lengths of up to 28 feet or
more but height wise they are around
three to four meters or 10 to 13 feet
16 the health swarm seed in Kingdom Kong
the hell swarm of large bad light
monsters with rough brown skin fur on
the back of their necks small hats with
sharp teeth spikes running down their
bags with large somewhat shredded wings
that possess orange membranes they are
smaller minions of the Titan called
camazods and they stand more than 4
meters or 13 feet tall
number 15 the geode insect its body is
reminiscent of a rock with a rough
texture and irregular shape the
creature's size is notable indicating
its formidable presence however what
sets it apart are the Striking features
within its chests blue and aquamarine
geodes cash GI their sparkling Beauty
drawing attention and hinting at the
hidden wonders within this creature is
around 5 meters or 16.5 feet tall
14 the spirit tiger seen in the comics
Kingdom Kong the spirit tiger resembles
an abnormally large Bengal tiger or a
white tiger with antlers the serrated
Stripes run down the spirit Tiger's body
are composed of epidermal leaves that
Shimmer in the soft breezes it is around
16.5 feet tall or 5 meters with the
antlers included
number 13 the mother long legs these are
gigantic spider-like creatures that
stand around 20 feet or 6 meters tall
they possess incredibly long legs that
resemble bamboo stalks allowing them to
blend in seamlessly with the surrounding
forests with their legs posing as plants
and their upper bodies held high above
the canopy mother long legs faces
resemble skulls being Light Beige in
color with large red eyes
number 12 the siren jaw this is a large
reptilian monster resembling a crocodile
covered in grass and roots and sometimes
even trees on its back it has a large
jaw with sharp teeth in it the monsters
also have a pair of small orange eyes
when it is half in water it resembles an
island and waits for prey like an ambush
Predator while it can reach 20 meters or
65 feet long its height however is
around 20 feet or 6 meters
number 11 skull crawlers these are large
amphibian creatures with only two long
for Limbs and no hind limbs as well as
long prehensile Serpentine tail they
have long and slender yet muscular
bodies several aspects of their
appearance are noticeably skeletal like
its face and spine skull crawlers are
long but their height varies from 12 to
30 feet or 4 to 9 meters tall excluding
the skull devil
number 10 the hawk essentially a
sidekick or a companion of Kong the hawk
is a reddish pink bird that is gigantic
in size compared to a human but still
small against Kong the hawk could easily
carry off the dog which is itself around
8 feet tall this flying creature is a
non-hostile animal and works alongside
the iwi tribes and calm it is around 9
meters or 30 feet tall with a very huge
wingspan
number nine the giant chameleon seen in
the series The Creatures somewhat
resembled chameleons having a long torso
short and stout clot Limbs and a long
prehensile tale that is often kept in a
curled posture the head contains a flat
almost featureless face forward facing
eyes bony outgrowth and a large robot's
jaw with sharp teeth they are 30 feet or
9 meters tall and easily around three
times as long
number 8 the magma Turtle the magma
turtle is a gigantic Turtle covered in a
rocky shell giving it the appearance of
a statue when not moving several palm
trees grow from the top of its shell the
magma turtle is a docile herbivorous
creature and does not fear predation
because of its size around 12 meters or
40 feet tall and also due to its hot
lava biology
number seven the scar Buffalo these
resemble abnormally large water
buffaloes they possess incredibly large
horns that have forked into at least
three branches they also have algae
covering their bodies probably due to
their habit of being submerged
underwater their backs possess a large
amount of foliage allowing for proper
camouflage scar buffaloes can reach
Heights of up to 45 feet or 13.7 meters
number six the Spore mantis seen in the
2017 movie but as a juvenile both the
body and the limbs of the spermantis
resemble Fallen trees in fact the bark
is a part of a species epidermis beneath
this deceptive layer lies a parasitic
slug-like creature with a very strong
jaw the adult specimen can reach at a
height of up to 50 feet or 15 meters and
are predators but with less energy so
than the skullcrawlers or the giant
chameleons
number five the Myers Quail the red
aquatic Master scene in the 2017 movie
is a Maya squid and it has a rounded
bulbous mantle that is similar in
appearance to that of an octopus it also
possesses eight long and thin arms its
entire body is red in color and it
functions as an aquatic Ambush Predator
since it is a sea creature its height is
irrelevant its overall size however is
110 feet or 33.5 meters
number four the skull devil also known
as the big one or ramarak the specimen
is the largest skull crawler on the
island as of 1973. there is another one
seen in the series it has the same
appearance like her species except that
she is much larger since she is almost
the same size as Kong around 95 feet or
29 meters tall her head is modifying
larger and somewhat angled while her
tail is armed with a form of a club or a
fin
number three camazods scene in Kingdom
Kong this Titan resembles a giant
demonic bad with rough brown skin fur on
the chest and the back a comparatively
small head with Jagged horns and sharp
teeth and large shredded Wings adorned
with sharp bone-like protrusions red
eyes broken horns and a long spiky tail
that is camazods it is 164 feet of 50
meters tall and has a wingspan of 402
feet of 122 meters
number two the Kraken the Nemesis of
Kong in the series this Titan's form
consists of a light blue octopus-like
body with multiple suction cup covered
tentacles smaller manipulator rare
tentacles and massive Claude volumes
it's immense bulbous head showcases two
sets of glowing orange eyes also gills
on the side and a serpentine body and a
formidable bird like B containing sharp
teeth we estimate it to be 250 feet or
76 meters tall and it can glow in the
dark
number one gong he is undoubtedly the
biggest monster and the sole surviving
Titan of Skull Island gong was initially
103 feet in 1973 and he grew larger as
time passes by in the birth of Gom he
was around 200 feet in Kingdom Kong he
was 270 feet tall and finally in gbk he
reached a height of 337 feet or 102
meters currently gone has changed his
permanent address to Hollow Earth take
note Amazon Prime
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
and new videos here on this channel take
care fam